this video is a follow-up to the trick
that I taught you for determining an
electron withdrawing or an electron
donating group on an aromatic ring and I
want to point you to that video if you
haven't watched it yet you'll want to
see the trick in action first and in
this video I'm going to show you a few
examples that do not apply and I'm going
to go into the one example that my
awesome viewers figured out where the
trick just doesn't work let's get into
it the first group that we're going to
talk about is alkyl groups for this
example let's take an aromatic ring with
just a methyl on it this count on is
toluene now I have to admit this
compound actually does follow the trick
we have carbon bonded directly to the
ring and hydrogen's bonded to that
hydrogen atoms are slightly less
electronegative than carbon atoms but
the problem here is we don't think about
hydrocarbons having polarized bonds and
hydrogen is way to the left on the
periodic table so we can't just
reconstruct that little portion of the
periodic table and think about our
trends which is a really practical thing
to do in just a little bit of
memorization we kind of have to just
know this and so we want to understand
this in a way that works better when
you're sitting down and taking a test
it's like oh my gosh was that an
electron donating or an electron
withdrawing group so let's look at
resonance in this compound and the first
thing I'm going to do is just push the
electrons in this bond so just one pair
of electrons and let's see which
direction we should push our electrons
to get a good resonance structure in
this charge separated resonance form we
have a positive charge on this carbon
and a negative charge where the methyl
is well carbo cations are more stable
when they're more substituted and so
this carbo cation here is just secondary
it's bonded to two groups let's look at
what would happen if we pushed electrons
in the other direction so the electrons
are moving on to this
carbon atom in this resonance form now
when we push our electrons this way we
get a tertiary carbo cation this ch3 can
actually donate electron density through
an effect called hyper conjugation and
that's what makes the tertiary carbo
cation more stable so this is a much
better resonance form and we shouldn't
even consider this one so now we're
gonna draw more resonance forms for this
we're gonna just push two electron pairs
at a time so we're gonna push this one
and this one and that's how I tell my
students to start out when you're
writing resonance forms don't try to
push through a whole conjugated system
if you're not seeing it yet if you push
too if you make two arrows push two
pairs of electrons you'll be able to see
each resonance form that's contributing
so let's try that this lone pair pushes
in this one we don't want to make five
bonds to carbon right here so this
electron pair goes up onto that carbon
and let's draw what we get and in our
final resonance form that will draw
we're gonna push these in push this
double bond up onto this carbon so that
we don't make five bonds to that carbon
right there now although these resonance
forms don't contribute as much as this
one that's not charge separated they do
contribute and so the most electron rich
positions are here here and here
so from this analysis we can say that
alkyl groups are ortho-para directors
but since carbon doesn't have a lone
pair on it that it can push directly
into the ring or anything like that they
are weak activators of the Ring the next
group we're going to look at is the
halogens here we have bromobenzene we
really couldn't discuss this in the last
video because we were looking for
substitution where this was bonded to
something else and we use that to
evaluate whether or not it would be an
electron withdrawing group or an
electron donating group but the bromine
isn't bonded to anything else so what do
we do in this case what we have to think
about this more chemically the halogens
are actually quite a unique example
inductively they draw electron density
out of the ring however each halogen has
three lone pairs on it now like we saw
in the last video these lone pairs can
actually be pushed into the ring by
resonance if we push one of our lone
pairs in to avoid making five bonds to
this carbon we'll have to push on to the
adjacent carbon atom and we get this so
here's a resonance form one of our
contributing structures with a negative
charge at the ortho position let's take
it to arrows at a time and see the next
resonance form we can see electron
density at the para position finally we
can draw arrow pushing to show one more
structure with a negative charge at the
ortho position so the halogens are also
ortho-para directors now the halogens
just aren't quite as good at donating
their electrons by residents as
something like oxygen or nitrogen so
this inductive effect is actually pretty
strong so although these resonance forms
make the halogens ortho-para directors
this inductive effect is pronounced
enough that these are deactivating
groups so bromo benzene is less reactive
than benzene the last group I want to
talk about in this video is the Nitro so
group and this is where you guys got me
this is where my trick fell apart and I
want to give a little shout-out to V
dent thanks for watching thanks for
commenting and so I could look into this
this is kind of a weird example so we
have nitrogen directly bonded to the
ring it's bonded to oxygen which is more
electronegative than itself and so we
would predict that this would be an
electron withdrawing group and undergo
medicine stitute and that's just not
true now these are not your typical
electrophilic aromatic substitution
conditions and that's because this
nitroso group can actually complex with
lewis acids so we need really careful
special conditions to even do these
reactions and they're not very efficient
because the nitroso group itself is
really reactive even this compound will
tend to bond to itself in a dimer so two
of these can come together insert under
certain conditions
so typically once people make the
nitroso compound they mean to react the
nitroso group and since it's so reactive
it's really a typical to be doing other
reactions on it like EAS but that
doesn't mean your professor won't think
that this is a really cool problem and
ask you to consider it and think about
it so we have to understand why this
goes the way it does this nitrogen atom
here is neutral we're showing three
bonds to it there's no charge and that
means it has a lone pair of electrons on
it so just like the halogens we can push
these electrons into the ring and draw
resonance forms and again like the
halogens we can continue pushing around
the ring and these have electron density
at the ortho and para positions so the
nitroso group does not work with my
trick and is an ortho para director
though the para Products dominate in
this inefficient reaction because of
steric hindrance of an electrophile
approaching at the ortho positions
thanks so much for watching I'm humbled
by how many views I had on the first
version of this video that with the
trick and I really want to do a nice
follow-up for you thank you for
commenting and giving me a cool example
to integrate into this video about
groups that don't quite follow the trick
I hope you keep watching subscribe click
that bell so you get notifications and
we can do a lot more chemistry together